In lesson 7 we learned that the Y in mitochondrial chromosomes
can be used to trace both the maternal and paternal lines.
>> But let’s do a quick recap to learn why the Y
can trace the paternal side and the mitochondria can trace the maternal side.
>> All right, so let’s set up a little
scenario here, let’s imagine that I have biological children.
>> Congratulations.
>> Thank you, and I pass down my x chromosome, what sex will the
child be? Be a female, because the mother has two Xs so she can only
pass down the X. And you passed down an X,
and so you have a child with two Xs. Baby girl.
>> Exactly. Now, what happens if I pass down my Y chromosome?
>> Well, the mother again only passes down the X and you gave a
Y, and so an XY equals a baby boy. So you'd have a male child.
>> Exactly, and we can use this Y chromosome to trace back
father, to father, to father And that's how we trace the paternal line.
>> And the mitochondria
are only passed down by the mother. So they trace your maternal line.
>> Precisely. This means that if you're a male, you
can actually submit a DNA sample. And you'll get information
about your maternal and paternal lines because you have both
mitochondria and a Y chromosome. But if you're a female
you only have mitochondria. So you can't actually get your
paternal information just from your own DNA sample. You're going to
have to use someone else in your family. I want
you to tell me, Which of the following relatives would
you not want to use if you're a female
and you want to get information about your paternal lineage?